[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في رصيده العائلي اربعه شهداء من
ابنائه اضافه الى زوجته الدكتور خليل
الحيه عضو المكتب السياسي لحركه المقاومه
الاسلاميه حماس الحركه التي تقع بين مطرقه
الاحتلال والمواجهه الشرسه والمستمره معه
وبين سندان اداره العلاقات الخارجيه
العربيه منها والاقليميه والدوليه قبل
اسابيع شهدنا عوده الحركه الى دمشق بعد
قطيعه استمرت قرابه عقد من الزمن كان ذلك
اثرا اندلاع الثوره السوريه والمواجهه
الداميه بين الشعب ونظام بشار الاسد الذي
لم يتوانى لحظه واحده عن الاستخدام المفرط
للعنف بكل ما يحمله هذا العنف من معنى
وادوات واستعانه باي ميليشيا واي نظام
اجنبي لدحر شعبه الثائر المطالب بالحريه
والاصلاح والعداله والمساواه عوده حماس
لدمشق تفتح الباب للسؤال المر الذي تواجه
به الحركه دائما كيف تدير علاقاتها
الخارجيه اي معيار على وجه التحديد
والعلاقات الخارجيه ليست كل شيء ولا اول
القضيه او اخرها فالمواجهه الدائمه مع
المحتل واداره القطاع المحاصر محدود
الامكانيات والعلاقات بينها وبين المكونات
الفلسطينيه الاخرى وقدره الحركه الدائمه
على حمايه من لا يكون تحت حمايتها في
القطاع وملف القدس والضفه المشتعل دائما
ما تكون على طاوله النقاش في الحركه وقطعا
على سلم اولويات النقاش مع احد قياديها
الدكتور خليل الحيه عضو المكتب السياسي
لحركه حماس ورئيس مكتب العلاقات العربيه
والاسلاميه ضيف المقابله في هذه الحلقه
والحلقه التي تليها فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اهلا بكم
الى هذه الحلقه الجديده من المقابله
نستضيف فيها دكتور خليل الحيه عضو المكتب
السياسي لحركه حماس ورئيس مكتب العلاقات
العربيه والاسلاميه وكذلك نائب رئيس
الحركه في القطاع في قطاع غزه اهلا بكم
دكتور حياكم الله سعداء جدا بوجودك في
المقابله في هذه الحلقه والحلقه التي
تليها حماس اصبحت اليوم في المركز في في
هذا المشهد العربي الاقليمي المعقد لتمثل
فيه المواجهه مع دوله الاحتلال ربما
العنوان الرئيسي
في اي مرحله من مراحل المواجهه نحن خاصه
امام حكومه يمنيه متطرفه مشروحه من الواضح
انه مشروع الغائى للطرف الاخر لا تقبل باي
باي درجه من التسويات
بدايه نحن في هذه المرحله هي مرحله اعاده
الاعتبار لحيويه القضيه الفلسطينيه من
جديد في مرحله احياء القضيه الفلسطينيه من
جديد واعاده القها
وسطها في المشهد الاقليمي والدولي لانه
كان يراد في المرحله الماضيه كلها ان تنسى
القضيه الفلسطينيه وتصبح جزء من الحوار
السريالي بين السلطه وبين الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي برعايه
الامريكيه
المنحازه وتبقى القضيه الفلسطينيه يقدم
الاحتلال مشام القضيه وينهي على طريقته
الخاصه لكن اليوم الظروف التي تتهيا بشكل
كبير من سلوك للاحتلال ومن ومن قدوم علاه
غلاه المتطرفين والمستوطنين وقدوم هؤلاء
الارهابيين الى الحكومه الصهيونيه وللاسف
تعامل العالم معاهم بمعايير مختلفه في هذا
الوقت الذي تشهد فيه الحاله الوطنيه نضوجا
للالتفاف حول برنامج المقاومه من جديد
الذي تؤمن به حركه حماس وتتوسط انا
باعتقادي اننا في مرحله واعده من اعاده
القضيه الفلسطينيه من جديد على عن طريق
المقاومه وحسر العدو الكيان الصهيوني لانه
الكيان الصهيوني اليوم اصبح مكشوفا امام
العالم الكيان الصهيوني قدم حاله على مدار
سبعين سنه بتزور والبهتان دوله القانون
دوله الديمقراطيه واحده الديمقراطيه واحه
المساوا العداله كل ذلك اصبح يتهاوى اليوم
امام هذه الحكومه الفاشيه الظالمه بشكل
كبير وبالتالي هي فرصه لنا كفلسطينيين
ولكل حر وللعالم العربي والاسلامي لعزل
هذه الحكومه ومقاومتها استمرارا لمقاومه
الشعب الفلسطيني من عشرات السنين على طريق
التحرير الاحتلال ان شاء الله
مع هذه الحكومه ما بين الحركه وهذه
الحكومه الامر متعلق
بالكيان الصهيوني بقدر اطلاق قطعان
المستوطنين الاستهداف المقدسات والمسجد
الاقصى ودخول المسجد الاقصى واقتحامه في
مناسبات متعدده وهذا هو خط الاحمر الذي لا
يمكن ان نقبل بحمل الاحوال باعتقاد بقدر
ما هو العدوان الصهيوني واطلاق يد
المستوطنين لضد الشعب الفلسطيني ومقدساته
تكون حجم المواجهه واقترابها او بعدها
بمدى جاهزيه حركه حماس لخوض مواجهه كبرى
اليوم مع دوله الاحتلال واقصد بالجاهزيه
امرين جاهزيه العسكريه الداخليه
وايضا قراءه المشهد العربي والاقليمي
والدولي لخوض مثل هذه الموجه اولا نحن
منخرطون في المواجهه يوميا
وشهدائنا في كل يوم مع ابناء شعبان
الفلسطيني والمقاومه ان كان في نابلس او
في جنين او في قلقيليه فنحن منخرطون
وموجودون وشهدائنا مع شهداء الشعب
الفلسطيني تلتحف دمائهم كما تلتحف بنادقهم
رصاصهم في وجه الاحتلال ثانيا القوه
المتجهزه والجاهزه للانخراط المباشر في
دفع العدوان عن شعبنا من قطع غزه هي جاهزه
كما يقول على النده القرار اذا اخذ
وانخراط قطاع غزه بمواجهه الاحتلال فنحن
جاهزون بمواجهه شامله ولكن غزه ليست
فيمنها عن المواجهه اليوميه احنا في كل
يوم في مواجهه شعبيه عبر الحدود عبر بعض
المواجهات حول قطاع غزه هنا وهناك فنحن
لسنا بعيدين عن الميدان نحن منخرطون في
الميدان اقول هذه الحكومه الصهيونيه
القادمه من جديد التي تسفر عن طبيعتها
جاءت ببرنامج واضح تهجير الشعب الفلسطيني
ولا يمكن تطبيق البرنامج الصهيوني لهذه
الحكومه التي بتالفها تصمد
وبالتراجع عن برنامجها تسقط وبالتالي هي
ماضيه لحمايه قادتها
المجرمون المتطرفون المستوطنون وبالتالي
هذه الحكومه التي تحوي في في وزرائها
مستوطنون داخل حدود الضفه الغربيه
الاستيطان كله
شرعي او غير قانوني لكن هذه الحكومه هي
التي تصب الزيت على النار تؤجج الصراع
داخل فلسطين وربما تنقل خارج المنطقه
ولذلك باعتقادي ان العالم اليوم غير مرتاح
لهذه الحكومه ويراها انها تزعجه ويراها
انها تحرجه وامام الاداره الامريكيه التي
تريد تهدئه المنطقه لتطبيق ما تريد من
اهداف ومن سياسات ان كان في صراعها في
الشرق او في مواجهه بقاء المواجهه في
اوروبا هناك تاكل الاخضر واليابس في حاله
استنزاف لاوروبا وروسيا معا امريكا تريد
لروسيا ان تستنزف اوروبا ان تستنزف لتطبق
مشاريعها في ظل هذا باعتقادي ان من الواجب
على علينا جميعا كفلسطينيين ان وجدت
الحكومه بكل الاشكال بالمقاومه ونحن
متفقون على ذلك بالمناسبه نحن كفلسطينيين
متفقون على مواجهه هذه الحكومه بكافه
الاشكال ميدانيا بكل الاشكال المقاومه
بالمسلحه وال وغير ذلك وسياسيا بعزلها
امام المنظومه الدوليه في كل المحافل
الدوليه هذه هي باعتقادي
الحاله الراهنه التي يعيشها شعب فلسطيني
وانا اعتقد ان ناقوس الخطر يدق على
المنطقه والمواجهه من خلال سلوك هذه
الحقوه الصاروخيه العسكريه لكتائب القسام
كيف تبدو اليوم مقارنه مع حالها في
الاعوام السابقه وقد خبط مواجهات
استثنائيه وتاريخيه في 21
وغيرها حماس امنت بان مشروع المقاومه وهو
مشروع التحرير الذي يقربها من فلسطين بشكل
كبير وبذلك عكفت لدفع كل ما ما تملكه من
قوه بشريه وماديه وتوظيف علاقاتها
السياسيه والشعبيه والرسميه لتطوير برنامج
المقاومه بشكل كبير وبالتالي اليوم نحن
نقول ان حماس ومع الفصائل الفلسطينيه
تمتلك قوه قادره على نجم العدوان وتعزيز
المعادلات بيننا وبين اكبر واكبر بل
ومفاجات اكثر من سيف القدس على ماذا تعتمد
هذه القدره العسكريه للقسام والفصائل
الاخرى على الدعم فقط الخارجي الايراني
تحديدا ام ثمه قدرات ذاتيه تطورت على
الحركه على انتاج قوتها او على الاقل حد
ادنى من القوه الذاتيه تعتمد على الايمان
المطلق بعداله قضيه بعد الايمان بالله
فالعنصر البشري والعنصر القيادي الذي يدير
هذه الحاله هو عنصر مؤمن بقضيته لا يخشى
هذا الاحتلال لا يحسب له حساب ولا يحسب
للخسائر التي يمكن ان تدفعها من ذاته او
من شخص او من حوله ثانيا ايمان المحيط بنا
شعبيا كشعب فلسطيني بان هذا مشروع محتضن
هذه الترسانه العسكريه او هذه القدرات
العسكريه على محدوديه بالمناسبه يعني
لكنها قادره على ان تحدث معادلات لان
الاحتلال لا يستطيع ان يواجه مقاومه من
داخله لتوازن رعب معه دوله توازن الرعب
المعادلات الردع مع الاحتلال قائم على
وجود قوه داخل قطاع غزه
تستطيع ان تضرب الاحتلال في كل مكان وايضا
مقاومه داخل الضفه الغربيه متصاعده هي
اليوم تضرب الاحتلال في كل الاماكن من
خلال العمل المنظم او الاسود المنفلته
وتجديد دكتور ما يجري في الضفه ليس جديدا
بمعنى يعني عدم وجود الى كنت تطوره ما
الذي يجري هناك تحديدا لماذا تتطور هذه
الامور والعمليات ما علاقه حماس بها اولا
احنا في المقاومه الفلسطينيه مؤمنين بعمل
المشترك والوحده الوطنيه
السياسيه نامل منها لكن العمل الميداني
هناك حاله انسجام كامله في الميدان بين
ابطال وشبان الشعب الفلسطيني على اختلاف
الانتماءاته وبالتالي اليوم اصبح شعار حط
السيف اقبال السيف احنا رجال محمد ضيف
يردده الفتحاوي والجبهاوي والجهداوي
والحمسه والمواطن العادي لانه اصبح هذا
الشعار شعار نكايه بالاحتلال ورمز قوه
ورمزيه فلسطينيه اليوم مع الاعتزاز من
يرددونه بالقائد محمد الضيف وغير ذلك ان
اقول ما يجري اليوم في الضفه الغربيه بشكل
كبير هو ايماننا بان المقاومه الفلسطينيه
هي التي تردع الاحتلال ولا يتحق الانجازات
كما حققنا في انتفاضه الاقصى
وطردنا الاحتلال من
غزه من المستوطنات في غزه اليوم بلا
مستوطنات ومن شمال الضفه الغربيه عندما
انسحب شارون من قطاع غزه اقول ان هذه
المقاومه تهدف الى دحر الاحتلال وهي
متصاعده باشكال متعدده متصاعده بالعمل
المنظم للفصائل حماس وغيرها والجهاد
والشعبيه وكتائب الاقصى والعمل المشترك
المقاوم الملتحم والمتمثل في عرين الاسود
الذي يشكل ظاهره مجتمعيه مشتركه مع كل
الوطن بلا استثناء بل كل وهم لا يميز بين
هذا حماس وهذا انما لهم عدو واحد ايضا في
كتيبه جنين وهناك بدات الحاله تتكرر في
قلقيليه وطولكرم وفي الخليل وغير ذلك
فالحاله المشتركه هذه اصبحت عنوان ثم
الحاله المنفرده الشعب الفلسطيني كل مواطن
يستطيع ان يملك سكين
بارود حتى بسيارته حتى بعمله بالحجر
بيمتلك قطعه سلاح لان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
يا استاذ علي وللمشاهد العربي ولم لم يترك
لنا خيارا الا مواجهته الا ان الاستيطان
عندما تعلن هذا الحكومه منهم سيجلب مليون
مستوطن الى الضفه الغربيه هؤلاء الذين
قضوا على ما تبقى من وجود فلسطين حتى في
الضفه الغربيه فلم يوجدوا لنا مكان الا
تعزيز
التصعيد في المواجهه مع طرفين الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وهي مواجهه مستمره ولكن ايضا
مع السلطه الفلسطينيه ومع الاجهزه الامنيه
هناك هل تطور هذا تطورت هذه المواجهه هل
تمت تعقيدات احنا عدونا المباشر الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وهذا نحن متفقين عليه نحن حتى
وبعض ابناء الاجهزه الامنيه السلطه تقوم
في بعض الاحيان بدور غير وطني
تقوم بدوره للاسف التنسيق الامني هي تلتزم
باتفاق العقبه والاحتلال لم يلتزم به ولم
يقروه وهذا مؤسف وهذا مودان وهذا لا نقول
لكن لا نجعل ابناء الاجهزه الامنيه لا سمح
الله هم خصومنا واعدائنا نختلف معهم نختلف
مع السلطه ندين بعض سلوكه السلطه اليوم في
اجراءاتها وسلوكها هي معيق لتطبيق للوصول
الى المشروع الوطني ومعيقلي للمقاومه
لكنهم ليسوا اعداء بالامس في جنين احد
ابناء الاجهزه من الرتبه نقيب استشهد مع
ابنائنا هناك وبالتالي ابناءهم ابناؤنا هم
اخواننا هم فلذات اكبادنا لكن لهم قياده
لها مشروع هنا وهناك لا باس لكنهم هم جزء
من اصيل من الشعب الفلسطيني نحن ندعوهم
ندعو السلطه وندع الامنيه للتوقف الفوري
عن التنسيق الامني وعن لا سمح الله
الاستجابه لاي شروط لم يعد لنا ايها
الاخوه خيار الا ان نكون موحدين في مواجهه
هذه الحكومه وم الاحتلال والسلطه عليها ان
تواجه هذه هذه الحكومه امام العالم لذلك
لا خيار ولم يعد هناك شيء في الافق يسمى
لا تسويه ولا غير ذلك وبالتالي احنا
نحاول ان نتعامل مع سلوك السلطه اللي احنا
ندينه لما يقف في وجه المقاومه لكن نتعامل
بروح الاخوه والوطنيه والمسؤوليه ولا
نجعلهم في ولا يجوز ان نجعلهم في صف
الاحتلال
رغم انخراطها الفاعل فيما يعرف بمحور
المقاومه الا ان حماس نجحت في احداث الحد
الادنى من التوازن المطلوب في علاقاتها
الخارجيه فعلى وقع اتساع رقعه الخلافات
السياسيه في المنطقه التي تعج بالازمات
تمكنت الحركه من نسج تقارب اللافت مع
المتناقضات ايران عدو اسرائيل وتركيا في
الطرف الاخر وبين هذا وذاك لم تقطع حماس
شعره معاويه مع مصر على الرغم من الخلاف
الكبير بين القاهره وجماعه الاخوان
المسلمين والتي انبثقت الحركه من رحمها في
شهر اكتوبر الماضي وبعد قطيعه دامت سنوات
فتحت حماس صفحه جديده مع النظام السوري
بعد مغادرتها دمشق بسبب امتناعها عن تاييد
بشار الاسد في وجه الثوره الشعبيه ظل ملف
تطبيع العلاقه مع النظام السوري مثيرا
للجدل داخل الحركه نفسها اذ تكررت دعواته
من بعض قادتها سرا وعلانيه ضروره
استئنافها لاعتبارات مرتبطه بالمقاومه
والعمل الميداني في حين حاول البعض الاخر
كبح هذا التوجه بالنظر الى تداعياته
الخطيره على الصوره حماس وخطابها ومجمل
ادبياتها
لكن التغييرات التي شهدت الحركه على مستوى
صفها القيادي الاول خلال الاعوام القليله
الماضيه رجح كفه اصحاب الراي القائل
بالتقارب مع دمشق اثر نجاحهم في تصدر
المشهد داخل الحركه بين ان هذا التغيير
ورغم اهميته لم يكن الدافع الوحيد لاعاده
العلاقات بين نظام الاسد وحماس فقد سرعت
وتيره تطبيع الدول العربيه لعلاقاتها مع
اسرائيل والتنوضعات السياسيه المستجده خطى
الحركه نحو دمشق
انت تدير مكتب العلاقات العربيه
والاسلاميه في الحركه في حركه حماس دكتور
خليل من اين تريد ان نبدا من دمشق التي
ذهبت اليها مؤخرا ام من مصر التي تشكل
يعني اكثر اهميه ربما لقطاع غزه والعلاقه
معها في غايه الاهميه لماذا
ذهبت الى دمشق هو اذا بدنا نريد ان نتحدث
على علاقات السياسيه لحماس نبدا من
استراتيجيه حماسه العلاقه احنا شعب تحت
الاحتلال لنا قضيه واحنا حركه مقاومه لنا
هدف
علاقاتنا السياسيه تنشا وترتكز بالدرجه
الاساسيه على خدمه القضيه الفلسطينيه
والحركه الوطنيه ومشروع المقاومه بقدر
الاقتراب والابتعاد من فلسطين ومن
المقاومه بقدر اقتراب وابتعادنا من اي
مكون في الامه رسمي وغير رسمي هذه علاقه
لا نتدخل في الشؤون الاخر الاخرين لا دول
ولا احزاب ولا حركات لا ندخل في المشاكل
البينيه في
الكينونه الواحده في الدوله الواحده ولا
في اشكالات الدول مع بعضها هذا ما نجح
حماس على مدار تاريخها من اكثر من 35 سنه
فلم ندخل في اشكاليات ومن هنا
لماذا خرجتم من دمشق في 2012 ولماذا عدتم
لها بعد عشره اعوام 2022 نحن في كل الدول
العربيه كشعب نحن ضيوف
وعلاقاتنا هناك انا قلت لا ندخل في الشان
الداخل خرجنا من سوريا لظروف متعدده لم
نشا ان ندخل في صراع في دوله بان الاخوه
في النظام والشعب في مشكله داخليه عندهم
في احداث بغض النظر عن تقييم كل جهه من
جهه نحن لسنا طرفا فيها وبالتالي راينا
الخروج
بسلام دون الدخول في اتون هذا الصراع هو
الحل الامثل وهذا الاجتهاد ولذلك لم لم
ندخل في سجال مع الاخوه في سوريا لا
بالاعلام ولا بغيره اليوم سوريا
لسؤالك لماذا عدتم اليها سوريا ونحن فيها
من قبل ومن بعد سؤال الدكتور بس عفوا
الخروج كان برايك اليوم اليوم خطا البعض
يرى ان خروج حماس كان خطا وعودتها كانت
خطا ايضا
شوف يقدر كل وقت بوقته عندما خرجنا كانت
تقدير صوابا كان رهن عن الربيع العربي
والتغيير كان التقدير في ذلك الوقت صوابا
نحاكمه في وقته وانا قلت الدافع عننا لا
نريد ان نكون جزء من صراع موجود في دوله
نحبه ونحب نظامها وشعبه اختلف النظام مع
الشعب في لحظه من اللحظات لاي سبب كان نحن
لسنا جزء من هذا الخلاف
بقاؤنا في سوريا ربما كان يسبب لنا حرج
هنا وهنا فخرجنا بسلام الان انت تحاكم
المرحله تحاكم في ظرفها في الوقت ذلك كان
قرار قياده الحركه الخروج من سوريا انت
تريد ان تحاكموا هذا للمعطيات التي تلت
لكن في وقته كان القرار صوابا اليوم اليوم
كيف تراه دكتور
الخروجه من العوده لا الخروج
يعني كان
كان يسعى الحركه ان يبقى لها جزء كما بقي
الفصائل حد ادنى من تمثيل وكان هذا مقبول
لكن هذا الاجتهاد لا نخطئه بعد ذلك لانه
لكن كان بامكان الحركه لو بقيت كما بقيت
بعض الفصائل في وجود رمزي فلم نكن نقاطع
هذه الدوله وغيرها وكان هذا ممكن بالمتاح
دكتوره كنت على راس الوفد حماس الذي قابل
بشار الاسد هناك في دمشق ماذا حملت هذه
الزياره من كان يدفع باتجاهها من الطرف
الوسيط بهذا اللقب خاصه لو في حديث لم تكن
دمشق ترغب كثيرا او متحمسه حتى لعوده حركه
على مصلحه العلاقات السياسيه وخدمتها لهذه
القضيه وعلاقتنا سوريا دوله طوق سوريا
فيها شعبنا الفلسطيني سوريا ما زالت
لا لا تطبع مع الاحتلال سوريا ما زالت تمد
يدها للمقاومه وتحتضن الفصائل الموجوده
وتفتح ابوابها لذلك احنا بعد مده عدنا
التقييم ما يدري في المنطقه
المنطقه اليوم يعاد ترتيب اوراقه من جديد
على فصله كما لو كان جزء مع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه جزء ضد المقاومه الفلسطيني في
محاوله استهداف للمقاومه الفلسطينيه كيف
نقوي وجود الشعب الفلسطيني نقوي حضورنا
داخل الشعب الفلسطيني
ونجلب رافعه جديده للقضيه الفلسطين نحن
نريد ايضا ان سوريا ان تتعافى مما هي فيه
وان تعود لدورها الطليعي ودورها القومي
والعربي والاسلامي كدوله محوريه في عمليه
في المنطقه ودعم القضيه الفلسطيني انا
اريد ان اطمن كل الجمهور العربي والاسلام
المحب انه لم يطلب منا احد اعاده العلاقه
مع مع سوريا ولكن قراءتنا السياسيه لما
يجري في المنطقه وضروره ان تقوي الحركه
علاقاتها مع الدول المحوريه والمهمه
المتواجد في اشعبنا الفلسطيني والملاصقه
الفلسطينيه والتي ما زالت تدعم ولديها
الجاهزيه لدعم المقاومه الفلسطينيه ولذلك
هذه القراءه مع ما يجري في المنطقه اليوم
من اعاده وتركيب وبناء تحالف ضد المقاومه
هنا وهناك فكان اندفاعنا لهذه الاولى فلم
يطلب منا احد
ثانيا
ذهبنا واحنا تحدثنا عن الجميع
وفي اطورنا القياديه ما كان في وساطه
ايرانيه في هذا الامر لا لم تكن هناك لا
طلب من ايران ولا وساطه من ايران قال له
كان في برود من زاويه دمشق في عوده
العلاقه ايضا هذا اشيع لكنه ليس صحيحا
يعني كان النظام مرحب بالعلاقه واحنا
سالنا قبل ان نذهب
فعندما سالنا قال النظام مرحب ممثل برئيسه
بشار الاسد يرحب بالعلاقه وسوريه مفتوحه
برئاسه زياد دخاله حركه الزياده يعني لم
يكن وفدا لحماس وحماسيه كب اكبر حركات هو
اولا الوفد تم الاتفاق عليه بهذا الشكل
انه احنا وقت قيادي من الفصائل الفلسطينيه
تتوسط وحماس واخونا ابو طارق النخاله امين
عام الجهاد الاسلامي وانا اقدم على نفسي
كامن عام كصديق واخذ وصفتها بانها زياره
تاريخيه ومجيده بعدما خرجت في المؤتمر
الصحفي الوصف كان
الانعطاف التي ما تحدثه هذه الزياره من
تواجد حماس في سوريا وايضا لاعاده
الاعتبار
للعمل المقاومه للمرحله وباعتقادي انه هذه
زياره تاريخيه لانه تعيد الاعتبار لتوسط
حماس في المنطقه من جديد لانه الناس اصبحت
انقسمت على حماس كان الاسلامي والقوم
والعلماني والعربى كل ما حماس لما خرجنا
من سوريا انقسمت الناس علينا وبالتالي
عندما تعود حماس الى سوريا وراينا اثار
ذلك في علاقاتهم الاحزاب العربيه والقوميه
واليسار ولذلك عادت حاله الانسجام بيننا
وبين مجرد ما زرنا وبالتالي كان محور هذا
لذلك كندا فقول يوم ما زرنا راينا الترحاب
والحجب الوفد بشكل كامل والترحاب بوافه
حماس طب ماذا انتجت دكتور مكتب لحماس قريب
اولا نحن متفقون مع الاخوه في سوريا على
اعاده العلاقه وتطورها بالتدريج هم مرحبون
بوجود مكتب لحماس ومرحبون
لم ترحب دمشق انا اقول لك انا الذي افاوض
وانا الذي اذهب انا اقول للاخوه في سوريا
مرحبون بوجود المكتب لحماس وبوجود ممثل
لحماس في سوريا يدير اعمالها وغير ذلك نحن
يعني في سياستنا ان نعود الى سوريا بشكل
متدرج وان نراعي الظرف العام في سوريا
وانا اقول انا
ذهبت انا وغيري من قيادات الحركه مرات ليس
مره ولا ثنتين ولا ثلاثه ولا اربعه نحن
نتردد الى سوريا وع مع الاخوه قبل الزياره
الاخيره تقصد او بعدها
الزياره التي التقينا فيها السيد بشار
الاسرائيلي
ذهبنا زيارات متعدده بعد ذلك واعتقد ان
العلاقه مع سوريا تسير بشكل الطبيعي
بالشكل المتدرج الذي نريده بعلاقاتنا مع
الفصائل بعلاقاتنا مع شعبنا وهناك تطور
طبيعي لهذه العلاقه نحن نسير به بشكل جيد
انا اقول انه احنا هذا الوضع الطبيعي
لعلاقتنا ان كان مع سوريا او العراق او
مصر او الاردن او السعوديه متى تسمى
الممثل لكم في دمشق هل ينتظرنا موعد معين
لتسميه ممثل نحن من نتاخر يعني القضيه عنا
بس قضيه اداريه مش ليس مرتبطا هل سيكون
مستوى الحضور مثل ما كان عليه الامر في
2012 ام اقل بكثير عليه الان الظرف يعني
نقدر وفق الحاجه يعني اما الاخوه في سوريا
مرحبون في كل الاتجاهات لكن انت تريد
الناس ظروف سوريه صعبه في الدمار والحاجه
والفقر لكن احنا بصراحه سوريا تعنينا بكل
مكونات اسوريه احنا بدنا نريد سوريا
الموحده كشعب ماذا ينتظر حماس من هذه
العلاقه اذا ما تحدثنا بشكل براجماتي يعني
بمعنى فائده ما تنشا عن العلاقه مع مع
النظام السوري التواجد في قلب الشعب
الفلسطيني في المخيمات
اعاده الاعتبار لكينونه حماس انها متصالحا
مع كل العرب والاسلامي الرسمي وغير رسمي
اعاده الاعتبار لما يمكن ان تقدم مجددا
سوريه او على ارض السوريه في برنامج
المقاومه دعم للمقاومه البعد
والعمل المباشر مع الفصائل الفلسطينيه من
قلب دمشق طيب دكتور هذا الحوار السياسي
هذا الشق السياسي ثم تم معيار اخلاقي في
في خاصه فيما يتعلق بحركات مقاومه نضاليه
اسلاميه تاخذ مواجهه كبرى وتقف الامه
وصفوف الامه مع حاول تؤيدها الشعب السوري
دفع نتيجه دفع اثمان كبيره في هذه الموجه
انتم لستم معنيين بهذه المواجهه لستم طرفا
فيها ولكن امام هذه الدماء الكبيره وامام
هذا التاييد الداعم لقضيه الفلسطينيه
وللمقاومه الفلسطينيه الاسلاميه تحديدا
حماس الم يثر مثل هذا السؤال السؤال
الاخلاقي المتعلق بعوده العلاقات مع
النظام السوري
اولا
[موسيقى]
لابد ان الامه ونحن اخلاقيا وسلوكيا مع
الامه بكل مكونات ومع الدوله الواحده بكل
بالنظام وبالشعب وغير ذلك ونحن ندعو
ونتمنى لكل دول في كل دول على حده
والبينيه ان تعود الى افضل احوال لان هذا
يخدم قضيتنا الفلسطينيه اذا حماس اليوم
ارادت ان ترتب علاقاتها مع الدول ومع
الكيانات ومع الاحزاب وغير ذلك وفق
علاقاتها البينيه باعتقاد حماس ستخاصم
اغلب الامه
سنقول هذه الدوله مطبعه مع الاحتلال وهذه
الدوله لها مشكله مع المعارضه وهذه دوله
لها مشكله مع جارتها وغير فمع من نقيم
علاقات وبالتالي نحن اخذنا مذهبا وسياسه
واضحه لا نتدخل في شؤون الدول الداخليه
ولا البينيه وعلاقتنا مع هذه الدول
والاحزاب والحركات والشخصيات بفلسطين فقط
عندما نتكلم مع علاقتها مع فلسطين قربا
وبعدا منا وبالتالي تسخن وتبرد العلاقه مع
هذه الدوله او هذا الحزب او هذا الكيان
بقربه وبعده من فلسطين والقضيه الفلسطيني
اعاده موضع نظرتها للعلاقات الخارجيه انه
لدينا زاويه واحده فقط ما يهم نعل الصين
ما يهم القضيه نحن زاويتنا في علاقاتنا
باتجاه فلسطين وليس باتجاه اخر وبالتالي
نحن في اي دوله لا نناقش امرا غير
المتناقضات دكتور انتم حركه اخوان
المسلمين والاخوان المسلمين في سوريا هم
تيار المعارضه
بعد هذا المواجهه اللي بدات في 2011
ومضطرون لعلاقه مع النظام السوري في كل
مكان في اليمن انتم قريبون من ايران
القريبه الداعمه للحوثيين والاصلاح وفي
الطرف الاخر في المعركه اقصد كيف تدير
حماس علاقاتها في هذه بين هذه المتناقضات
نحن قبل ان نكون اسلاميين ومقاومين نحن
فلسطينيين نحن الشعب الفلسطيني المسلوبه
ارضه والمحتل مقدساته لنا قضيه عادله لنا
قضيه مهمه اسمها قضيه تحرير فلسطين
وبالتالي نحن نريد من كل انسان على هذه
البسيطه ان يدعمنا نريد من كل نظام ان
يدعمنا اذا ما دخلنا في اتون هذه الصراعات
وهذه الانقسامات وهذه الاتجاهات ضاعت
فلسطين فوق ما هي ضاعت ما نخلص وبدانا
ننتهي ولذلك احنا وضعنا بوصله امامنا من
يدعمنا نرفعه على رؤوسنا اذا اختلف مع اخي
خارج فلسطين انا لا ادخل في خلاف معك
وبالتالي هذه بوصلتنا وبالتالي على الامه
الامه تريد منا امور محدده احنا عرفنا
دكتور ماذا تريدون من من دمشق من النظر
ماذا يريد هو ممكن
بالسياسه كل طرف يريد من طرف الاخر فماذا
يريد النظام السوري اليوم اولا نحن من
يريد من النظام وليس النظام يريد منا يعني
باعتقاده نحن كحركه مقاومه الشعب نحن نريد
من الدول نحن نريد من الشعوب ان تدعمنا
لاننا في حماس
نقاتل راس
الافعى الذي يتضرر العالم من وجوده راس
الافعى في فلسطين اسمه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي نحن نقاتل راس الافعى كلما
اضعفنا راس الافعى اضعفنا اطرافه في كل
العالم وبالتالي هذا عهدنا مع الامه اليوم
ما يحدث في كل دول العالم ودول من شرور
نحن نعتبر ان اسرائيل له لها ضلع فيه
وبالتالي عندما نشغل اسرائيل داخل فلسطين
ونضعفها داخل فلسطين اذا نضعف تاثيرها
السيء خارج فلسطين وبالتالي انا بعتقد
اننا نقدم في حماس والشعب الفلسطيني في
المواجهه المستعره مع الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
في فلسطين نقدم اعظم هديه لكل
وعربي واسلامي وانساني حر يكره الاحتلال
ايا كان شكله عدوا الان هذا سوريا او غير
سوريا تريد منا هي لم تطلب منا شيئا
بالمناسبه لم يطلب منا شيئا قال كلمه
واحده هذه بلدكم ومرحب بكم في اي مكان
ونحن نقول لكم نرحب بكم في هذا كلما
زرناهم قالوا هذه اهلا وسهلا بكم في كل
وقت هذه بلدك زمان قابلت ابو الوليد السيد
خالد مشعل احنا ما كان رئيس المكتب
السياسي وكان يتحدث عن
الامتياز الكبير الذي كانت تحظى به حماس
في سوريا امتياز لا نهائي امكانيات كامله
تحرك بلا قيود وبلا حدود من الصعب اليوم
العوده لمثل تلك المرحله احنا قلنا كلمه
واحده عفوا بس هي تاكيد ان حماس دفع الثمن
كبيرا في 2012 نتيجه خروجها احنا نريد
بشكل واضح
قعدنا العلاقه مع الاخوه في سوريا
على طريق خدمه مشروع المقاومه على طريق
التحرير ونتمنى ونسعى لان نعود في سوريا
كما كنا وافضل في سوريا وغير سوريا
بالمناسبه ولذلك هذا هو هدفنا وباعتقادا
الاخوه في سوريا لا يمانعون لكن الظرف
سوريه اليوم ليس كسابق ظرف سوريا الحاله
ليس كساب
في اطار العلاقات العربيه اذهب لمصر
الدوله الكبرى والاهم بالنسبه
للحركه اظن يعني من الناحيه الجغرافيه
والتاريخيه وقيمه ومكانت مصر بشكل عام كيف
تقيم اليوم العلاقه مع مصر العلاقه مع
الاخوه في مصر طبعا مصر في قبل مصر
كموقعها ومكانتها ودورها ان كان في بشكل
عام او في القضيه الفلسطينيه دور محوري
وعلاقته من غزه مع غزه بشكل مباشر اكثر
حيويه واهميه العلاقات والنعم الاخوه في
مصر علاقه جيده او مستقره
ونسعى لتطويرها ومصر اليوم لها دور ايجابي
ان كان في التخفيف من معاناه الشعب
الفلسطيني في غزه في مشاريع الاعمار مصر
لها شهد في الحرب الاخيره مصر ايضا تتدخل
عندما تكون هناك مواجهات من الاحتلال ايضا
مصر تقوم اليوم تتطور اليوم في موضوع
المعبر والمسافرين ربما يكون ليس هو
المطلوب لكن يتطور اليوم الاداء في حركه
المسافرين عبر معبر رفح كل يوم افضل من ذي
قبل وبالتالي نحن علاقتنا مع الاخوه في
مصر يعني
جيده ونراكمها ونطورها نظير الاشكاليه مع
الاخوان المسلمين في مصر والمواجهه الكبرى
التي خاضها النظام الحالي وانتم حماس ايضا
الحركه ضمن اطار جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
هذا يجعل العلاقه دائما في ارتياب عدم ثقه
كامله لا يمكن ان تذهبوا للنهايه ولا
يذهبون هم للنهايه معكم هو اولا نحن نعلن
حالنا نحن اسلاميون ننتمي للمدرسه
الاسلاميه الوسطيه التي هي امتداد
للاخوان المسلمون انهم جزء منها ولكن احنا
قلنا بشكل واضح نحن نقدم حالا للعالم اننا
حركه وطنيه مقاومه فلسطينيه
يمتد جذورها الى الحركه الاسلاميه التي
تعتنقل المذهب الوسطي وبالتالي على العالم
ان يتعامل معنا بهذا الطريق ونحن هكذا
نقدم انفسنا وبالتالي نحن لا نضع علاقتنا
مع مصر جنبا الى علاقه مصرين مع الاخوان
هذا شانهم الداخل لا نتدخل فيه كما قلنا
في سوريا وبالتالي احنا كما نتمنى نتمنى
لمصر ونتمنى لكل لكل الدول كما هي علاقتنا
مع كل المكونات وبالتالي احنا كما قلت لا
نضع علاقتنا مع الدوله نحن نتعامل مع كل
دوله مع مكوناتنا نحن تعاملنا مع مصر ايام
الرئيس مبارك رحمه الله وثم ايام المجلس
العسكري ثم ايام الرئيس مرسي رحمه الله ثم
ايام الرئيس السيسي في كل مرحله نحن
نتعامل مع الدوله بكل مكوناته نحن لسنا
جزءا من
الدوله والاشكالياتها نحن نريد لمصر بكل
مكوناتكم داعمين لنا ننتقل للخليج
السعوديه كيف تبدو العلاقه مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والدوله الاكبر والاكثر
تاثيرا ايضا في المنطقه
هل تمت افوق هل تمت حديث هل ثمه محاولات
تجري كما جرت معها اماكن في اماكن اخرى
والله احنا نسعى دائما لعمل علاقات مميزه
وتطويرا مع كل الدول العربيه والاسلام نحن
لسنا في سبب باعتقادنا لسنا سببا في جمود
او برود العلاقه مع اي دوله عربيه ولكن
هذه الدول هي من تحدد نحن لم للاخوه في
سوريا في السعوديه ولا النسيم نحن لم
نضرهم ولن نضرهم نحن لا نتكلم لم نتكلم ما
يسيء لهم ولا نتكلم لكن الاخوه السعوديين
اخذوا اتجاه في
الابتعاد عنه ويعني ووصفنا باوصاف غير ل
مواجهه مع ايران انتم حلفاء لايران
وبالتالي الاستنتاج الطبيعي ان ينظر
لحماسك في موقع الخصم اكثر او البعيد على
الاقل يعني او الخلاف السعوديه
كان هناك خلاف سعودي ايراني السنوات طويله
وكان لنا علاقات مميزه مع الاشقاء في
السعوديه وكنا نلتقي مع مكونات الدوله ومع
خادم الحرمين الشريفين وكان لنا علاقات مع
ايران ونتحدث هنا وهناك على العلاقات مع
علاقاتنا مع ايران في السعوديه وعلاقتنا
مع السعوديه في ايران ولم يكن احد يتكلم
يقول لا اقطعها ولا اقطعن لم تكن علاقتنا
مع ايران هي سبب لتوجس العلاقه مع
السعوديه
وبالتالي لكن في ظروف نشات مع الربيع
العربي ومع هذه الاشكاليات ومع الظروف نشا
انه للسعوديه يعني تراجعت في علاقتها معنا
واعتقلت بعض الفلسطين وبعض اخواننا هذا
سبب يعني جمود العلاقه وبرودها نحن بكل
وضوحنا السعوديه تعنينا السعوديه تعانينا
كدوله من موقعه ومن مكانتها نحن لسنا في
غنى عن اي دوله عربيه وعلاقتنا معها لكن
لسنا من نحدد هذه العلاقه نحن
متواجدون جزء من شعبنا في السعوديه لكن
السعوديه من تقرر علاقتها مع الاخرين احنا
ايدينا ممدوده للسعوديه بكل اخوه بكل محبه
وبكل مسؤوليه وكل حاجه بالمناسبه للسعوديه
وغير السعوديه ولكن الاخوه السعوديين هم
من يقرروا العلاقه معنا ان تتقدم او تتاخر
ان تبرد او تسكن العلاقه مع قطر طبعا
استثنائيه الحكم وجود القيادات هنا
قطر
حفظها الله وزادها رسوخا وتطورا ونماء قطر
اخذت على عاتقه ان تقوم بان تواصل دعم
للشعب الفلسطيني ومواصله
دعم لنا ونحن هنا نجلس في ضيافه الاخوه في
قطر نشكرهم في كل يوم ولا
ان الاف الفلسطينيين
يدعون لقطر في الليل والنهار في غزه ما
تقدمه قطر للفلسطيني بشكل عام ولقطاع غزه
بشكل خاص
يقدر وسيكتب في صحافه التاريخ من يؤثر هذا
التواجد على خيارات حماس سياسيه والعسكريه
في المواجهه مع دوله الاحتلال الدكتور نحن
يا استاذ علي نحترم كل الدول بقدر ما كانت
علاقاتنا
وبقدر
وما لا نتدخل في شؤونهم نحن ناخذ القرارات
التي تناسبنا حتى ربما تكون لا تناسب هذه
الدوله لربما لا تناسب قطر ولا تناسب دوله
اخرى لكن الاحترام المتبادل للحق هم
يحترموا اختيارتنا ولا يتدخلوا فيها لكن
نحن خياراتنا ما يخدم شعبنا ويخدم قضيتنا
ويخدم مقاومته هذا هو المحور الاساسي والا
بنبطل حركه دكتور اكبر اشكاليه
يعني لا اعرف اذا كنا نصفها مشكله لكن
اكبر قضيه فيما يتعلق بعلاقات الحركه
الحركه هي العلاقه مع ايران اذا ما اتجهنا
الان من العالم العربي للدول الاقليميه
انتم لديكم علاقه مميزه واستثنائيه بيره
ما لديكم ايضا علاقه مميزه في تركيا
بقيادتها الحاليه الرئيس اردوغان العلاقه
مع ايران كيف تصفها بشكل يعني اصبحت كانها
ركيزه استراتيجيه في في سياسه الحركه
الخارجيه شوف احنا علاقتنا مع الاخوه في
ايران بشكل واضح هي العلاقه بدعم القضيه
الفلسطينيه ودعم المقاومه
وبالتالي نحن لا نتدخل في علاقات وسياسه
ايران في امورها التي تخصها لكن احنا
دائما نقدر كل من يدعمنا ويدعم الشعب
الفلسطيني ايران تقف مع الشعب الفلسطيني
وعن المقاومه بكل ما تستطيع كيف ما طبيعه
هذا الدعم
الايران تدعمنا سياسيا تقف مع المقاومه
كبرنامج وتقف مع حماسه القوى المقاومه
وتدعمنا بالمال والسلاح وكل المتطلبات ذلك
وتدفع عثمان من اجل ذلك نحن نقول من يمد
يده لنا نقول له شكرا ولذلك نحن نريد
الدعم من ايران ومن كل دول العالم في 2013
تراجع شويه بعد بعد الربيع العربي بعد
الخروج من دمشق اشرت في حديث حتى صحفي
قديم تراجع قليلا ولا كثيرا هو للحق احنا
يعني تراجع العلاقه السياسيه بينها وبين
ايران لكن للحق التواصل مع الخط العسكري
والامني والدعم
العسكري الرمان لم يتوقف ولكن
تخفضت العلاقه السياسيه تقريبا سنتين
ثلاثه اما الدعم العسكري والامني والمالي
للعسكر بقي متواصله لذلك يقالوا في في
موقفين في حركه حماس موقف حماس داخل
وقياداتها ومنهم الدكتور خليل والقسام
والسنوار والاسماء التي داخل غزه وموقف
ليس بعيدا لكنه متباين لقيادات الخارج ما
دقت مثل هذا التوصيف شوف
يثار دائما صحيح هذا كان يقال لكن انا
اقول لك بكل وضوح واسال من شئت لا خلاف
بين قياده حماس في الداخل والخارج على
اهميه وضروره العلاقه مع الاخوه في ايران
لما يقدمونه من دعم للقضيه الفلسطينيه
وللمقاومه هذا لا خلاف عليه لكن الناس
تحاول ان تصطاد في هل تمت اختلاف في تقدير
هذه العلاقه في شكلها فيما يظهر منها بين
الخارج والداخل انا اعتقد ان اقول من حيث
المبدا والقناع احنا في كل يوم نحن نقول
قراراتنا لا خلاف بيننا في العلاقه مع
ايران والعلاقه لا بد ان نطورها ونعززها
وهذا نتفق معه في الداخل والخارج الان
يحاول في بعض المواقف ربما تجد في بعض
المواقف بعض الاجتهادات يختلف انا واخي في
تقدير الموقف الاعلامي من هنا او غير غرته
اما اصل العلاقه وطبيعه العلاقه وتطوير
العلاقه والقبول الدعم المالي والسياسي
وغير ذلك لا خلاف بيننا على ذلك اما قد
يكون هناك اجتهاد اعلام من هنا وهناك قد
نختلف عن لكن اساس العلاقه لا خلاف عليها
معيرا وانا اقول مشكلتنا مع اي طرف اخر
ليس بمشكلتنا مع ايران ايران تدعمنا بكل
شيء نحن نطالب بقيه الامه ان تدعمنا نحن
نريد ان يبقى الدعم الايراني ويبقى دعم
الامه تركيا لا تقدم مثل هذا الدعم الذي
تقدمه ايران تركيا لا تدعم لا تقدم اي دعم
في الجانب العسكري وتركيا يعني في البعد
الانساني تقدم بعض الدعم من خلال المؤسسات
لماذا لا تفعل تركيا وينظر لها من الاوساط
العربيه والاسلاميه على انها اليوم تشكل
قياده اسلاميه كبرى فبالتالي يقصد ولديها
نزعه استقلاليه فلماذا لا تقدم تركيا شيئا
مالي لقضيه الفلسطينيه
فهو ما يمكن ان تقول تركيا تقول بقيه
الدول العربيه الملاصقه لفلسطين يعني ما
تقوله تركيا يمكن ان تقول اي دوله اخرى
هذا شانها ولكن هم يرفضوا ان يدعموا في
البعد العسكري اي اي شيء فتركيه يعني ونحن
نقبل بالمناسبه نحن في علاقاتنا السياسيه
نقبل بالحد الذي تعطيه اي دوله تركيا نحن
متواجدون في البعد السياسي والتنظيمي
والحركي احنا وابناء شعبنا في التجاره
وغير ذلك
حماس وغيره بالالاف موجودين كما باقي
الدول وهذا مقدر الان هذا ما تصعد تقدمه
تركيا على الراس والعين مصر تقدم هذا
الدعم
والحاضنه لغزه على الراس والعين السعوديه
كان في ظرف معين غيره نحن لا نقول وهكذا
ما تستطيع ان تقدمه دوله هذا احد اقول لهم
شكرا ولكن نحن نطمح لاكثر صحيح والله
طموحنا طموحنا ورجاؤنا الداخلي ان نزود
بالمال والسلاح والطيران وكل ما نملكه
لراحه العالم من الكيان الصهيوني وهذا
حقنا على الامه لكن هل الامه تستطيع اليوم
الان اقول تستطيع ولكن حسابات وتختلف
ولذلك نحن نقول للامه ادعمونا بالمال
والسلاح ونحن فيكم شر هذه هذا الكيان
لننهيه لا تدخله في حروب معهم لا تدخلوا
في حروب مع الاحتلال سهل الامور سهلوا
علينا واحمل ظهورنا وادعمونا بالمال
والسلاح ونحن نعاهدكم ونعاهد الامه ان
ننهي هذا الاحتلال الصهيوني على الارض
فلسطين بشعب الفلسطيني وفي الداخل متى
يمكن ان نرى لدى لدى القسام لدى حركه حماس
حركات المقاومه في غزه قدره ذاتيه على
انتاج يعني عسكري ليس لنا شيء كبير نظرا
للظروف ولكن الشيء الاقل يحمي القطاع
وحركات المقاومه ويجعلها قادره على
الاستمرار في نفس الزخم العسكري ليس سرا
ان نقول نجح الامريكان والاسرائيليين في
تجفيف منابع الدعم الخارجي اللوجستي
والامداد من الخارج الى حد كبير
ولكن عوض بالقدرات الانتاجيه من الداخل في
كافه المجالات يعني اليوم احنا في غزه
نصنع السيارات الطيارات المسيره
ونصنع الصواريخ
وبعض القطع السلاح وربما الرصاص
وبالتالي في غزه
عندما توقف الامداد او كاد ان يتوقف بفعل
الامريكان واتفاقيات اعالي البحار لكننا
لا نستسلم
لا نحن ولا من يدعمنا ولا من حلفائنا
ولذلك هناك يعني اصرار من المؤسسه
العسكريه الحمساويه ومع كل الوطن
الفلسطيني ان هناك حاله الانتاج والقدرات
وتطوير بالمناسبه
يعني لا ابالغ قلت اكثر من يعني الغالبيه
الساحقه من الصواريخ التي تطلق من غزه هي
انتاج محلي
يعني لو بلغوك اكثر من 95% اذا اللي
الحديث عن ان ايران هي من يزود ايران لا
نتحدث عن كل الدقائق والتفاصيل ايران تدعم
بالمال ايران تدعم ولا تدعم بالقدرات
وغير ذلك
والتدريب والمعلومات والتواصل
المباشر بشكل كبير هذا عمل كبير يعني انا
لست مختصا في العمل العسكري لكنه عمل كبير
لكن انا استطيع ان نقول ان حماس وكتاب
القسام استطاعت ان تبني بني عسكريه
انتاجيه داخل قطاع غزه في مجال التصنيع
يدخل على كل المجالات عده حروب خاضتها
حركات المقاومه على راسها حركه حماس
استطاعت ان تحدث توازنا مميزا واستثنائيا
مع دوله الاحتلال طوال عقد ونصف في قطعا
هدف هذه المواجهه هو الغاء
هذا الاحتلال كاملا كهدف بعيد المدى
والفين تحدثت عن قبول بحدود 67 وتسويه ما
يمكن ان تجمع او او يتجه لها فالحروب اما
تفضي الى انتصار طرف على طرف الكامل او
تسويه هل تعتقد انه التسويه اقرب ام
استمرار المواجهات اقرب لا يوجد في الكيان
الصهيونيه اخ علي احد يؤمن بان يكون هناك
تسويه واقامه دوله فلسطينيه داخل فلسطين
في الكينونه وفي القناعه الصهيونيه على
خافه الاحزاب الصهيونيه لا يوجد قناعه او
ايمان او انه يمكن للشعب ان يكون له كينون
او دوله بجوار ليش قدمته تنازل بقبول احنا
اولا انا قلت عملنا مقاربه نحن قناعاتنا
طرد الاحتلال من كل فلسطين من البحر الى
النار ولكن امام الحاله الوطنيه انت تجترح
توافقات مرحليه مع كل الوطني ونحن قلنا
نحن لا نمانع
باقامه دوله فلسطينيه
كامله السياده في الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه
والقدس بحدود عام 67 اللي في حدود دون ان
نعترف نحن بالاحتلال الاسرائيلي وعوده
اللاجئين وبالتالي اذا عاد اللاجئون
الفلسطينيون اللي بالملايين الى الى هنا
ونحن في حماس لانا لن نعترف اسرائيل وقلنا
هذا هذا الحد الادنى من التوافق الوطني لن
قناعتنا ولا رؤيه لكن هذا الحد التوافق
الوطني المشترك احنا نقبل به مرحليا نقبل
به لكن نون دون ان نقر في حماس ان باقي
فلسطين للاحتلال الاسرائيلي اعطونا نقول
للعالم اليوم هذا اتفاقنا الوطني للمرحله
اعطونا دوله فلسطينيه ب 67 كامله السياده
واعيدوا لنا اللاجئين وليفعل في التاريخ
احفادنا وابناؤنا ما يفعلون اذا دكتور
ماذا ستقدم حماس في المقابل اذا قابلت
دوله الاحتلال مثل هذا الامر نحن كجزء من
الحركه الوطنيه اذا ما اقيمت هذه الدوله
التي يتكلم الناس عنها اليوم وعنا وقدمنا
هذه المرونه والتوافق الوطني بالحد الادنى
يمكن الشعب الفلسطيني بتوافقه يقدم فتره
زمنيه مؤقته نسميها هدنه كما اعلن عن
الشيخ احمد ياسين ونحن قلنا ذلك لكن
السؤال هل هذا ممكن اليوم
باعتقادي غير ممكن غير ممكن لانه كل
المعطيات تتحدث بشكل واضح ان الاحتلال
الصهيوني يذهب مذهب طرد الشعب الفلسطيني
هذه الحكومه التي لم تبقي شيئا من الضفه
الغربيه للاستيطان بل تريد ان تجلب مليون
مستوطن الا الداخل هذه الحكومه التي تريد
ان تهجر للفلسطين في 48 يعني هذه الحكومه
الجديده
الجنسيات تغلق الجنسيات تطرد الفلسطينيين
من القدس احنا امام معركه جديده ربما تحدث
غدا في رمضان اللي هي تقسيم المسجد الاقصى
الزمني والمكان الحل الدولتين ما عدا
موجوده نعم تكلم عن فرضيات ليس له وجود
اليوم وبالتالي دعونا تقام لنا الدوله
ونقول ماذا يمكن ان يفعل الشعب الفلسطيني
اظل مكتب السياسي مدير العلاقات العربيه
الرئيس العلاقات العربيه
والاسلاميه في حركه حماس نائب قائد قطاع
غزه شكرا جزيلا لك اردنا في هذه الحلقه ان
نتناول الجوانب السياسيه لكن الجوانب
شخصيه كبيره ومسيره اودن استعرضها معك في
الحلقه القادمه ان شاء الله ان شاء الله
بالتفصيل ومسيره التشكل والتعليم وكذلك
العمل في في الحركه قبل نشاتها وبعدها
نشاتها ان شاء الله شكرا جزيلا لكم
مشاهدينا الكرام شكرا لكم على طيب
المتابعه كما ذكرت الاسبوع المقبل ان شاء
الله الجزء الثاني مع الدكتور خليل حياه
سنتناول فيه مسيرته الشخصيه وتشكله وترقيه
ايضا في المواقع القياديه في حركه
المقاومه الاسلاميه شكرا لكم على طيب
المتابعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]